So now I'd like to
introduce today's speaker.
Today's featured speaker is Olav Solgaard.
Olav Solgaard is the professor
of electrical engineering
of Stanford University, and the director
of the Edward L Ginzton Laboratory.
He earned his PhD degree from Stanford
University in 1992, where his doctoral
dissertation was the basis for the
establishment of a Silicon Valley firm,
Silicon Light Machines, also known as SLM,
cofounded by Dr. Solgaard in 1994.
He was a postdoc at UC Berkley,
and in 1995 he joined
the electrical engineering faculty of
the University of California Davis.
His work at UC Davis lead to the invention
of the multiwavelength fiber optical
switch, which has been developed into
commercial products by several companies.
Professor Solgaard's research
interests include optical MEMS,
photonic crystals, atomic force
microscopy, and solar energy conversions.
He has authored more than 300 technical
publications and holds 50 patents.
He is a fellow of The Optical Society of
America, the Royal Norwegian Society of
Sciences and Letters, and the Norwegian
Academy of Technological Sciences.
He also serves as the academic director
for the new Internet of Things graduate
certificate offered through the Stanford
Center for Professional Development,
which we will talk a little bit
more about at the end of the hour.
So now I'd like to turn
the floor over to Olav.
>> Thank you very much, Stephanie, and
thank you to all of you out there who have
logged on to hear me talk about things
that are very dear to my heart.
I've been working with sensors for a long
period, a long time, so smart sensors
are something that I'm very excited
about and have been for a long time.
The Internet of Things, this newer base
also has changed how we look at sensors
quite a bit, and that's part of what
I'm going to be talking about today.
So here's my outline, I'm going to talk
a little bit about sensor fundamentals.
Because that allows you to sort of
understand a little bit better how you
should design and operate sensors in the
Internet of Things sort of environment.
And I will make the argument, and
I hope I make a strong argument that MEMS
sensors, meaning sensors that are made
with silicon foundary technologies.
And I'll talk a little
bit about what they are.
All the ones that really are going to
enable the Internet, and has been doing so
up till now, and will do it even
more on that in the future.
And then I will, towards the end, once
we have sort of understood what a MEMS
sensor is and what it does, I'll talk
a little bit about Internet of Things and
how that is going to be
enabled by MEMS sensors.
And I'll talk a little bit about
the opportunities that I see.
And really inviting you to sort of think
about what Internet of Things can be for
you in terms of challenges and
opportunities.
So that's towards the end, but before I
even jump into the center part of it,
I just wanted to say a few things about
my perception on Internet of things.
And Internet of Things is
showing here as a pink cloud,
has many components to it, obviously.
It is sensors, or
I have the perspective of sensors,
and many other people look at
tit from different perspectives.
So you might be an expert on the Internet
and how you use the Internet.
Of course that's really the backbone
that ties everything together.
Machine learning and signal processing
at the far end is also going to be very
important, and many other opportunities
and challenges are there.
Circuits and embedded systems are the
things that sort of takes the sensors and
connects them to the Internet.
So you can think of it in this way,
the sensors are the structures that allows
us to interact with the real world.
And then they take it all the way to the
other end through the embedded systems,
through the circuits, through the
Internet, through machine learning, and
signal processing into the digital world.
So the sensors are the interface,
if you like.
And that's why I think they
are the most important,
of course other people have
different perspectives on that.
But here's some of the reasons why
I think sensors are so important.
You use them just everyday,
this is two very,
very incomplete lists that sort of
sensors that you use every day,
involved with sensors are in
your cellphone in particular.
In that you have a accelerometers in
there, those are the ones that allows your
screen to rotate so
the phone knows what orientation it is.
Gyros do some of the same things,
also complements your GPS signals.
Timing circuits, microphones,
light sensors, cameras, all these things,
heartbeat sensors, and proximity sensors.
The heartbeat sensor is the one
that's fits in your Fitbit or
sort of device like that, that people
more and more are using these days.
In your car you have many,
many dozens of sensors, and
I'm sort of showing
an incomplete list here.
The next thing I wanted to do was
to talk about how sensors work.
And of course,
if you look at this list, and
this is a partial list, you'll say,
that's not a meaningful question,
because they obviously work
in many different ways.
And so
I'll try to find some commonalities so
I can say a few things about how sensors
should work and how they should scale.
So let's take a look at some of
the ones that are out there.
This is Standford work,
this is a company called Si Time.
What they do is make clocks, essentially.
So these are clocks that
are buried in your silicon chip.
And timing is, of course, super important
when you do communications, obviously.
This is the type of stuff that
sits behind everything you do.
You use it all the time,
you don't even know it.
The really cool things about
this particular clock,
if you like, is it work exactly like
your grandfather clock at home.
It has an oscillator and
the frequency of that oscillation is
what gives you the timing information.
Only this is a much more advanced
thing and much more stable thing and
much better in terms of keeping
time than your grandfather clock.
What we have here is,
if you look at this piece that is sort of,
you can see as a cross section here.
That is a mass that is
suspended on a spring.
And it's driven and resonance frequency,
we'll talk a little bit more about
a resonance frequencies in a second.
But that needs to be very,
very, well defined so
that you can get a very good time signal.
So this is a mass on
the spring essentially.
Here's another example,
this is a MEMS gyroscope.
There are several things
I want to say about this,
this is a very complex structure.
The first I showed was from Stanford,
this is from UC Berkeley.
I don't want to be too Stanford-centric,
although you might feel that I am
already when I go through these sides.
This is from Berkeley, and
the part that's the sensor is the gyro.
And so
this is something that senses rotation.
So it's similar to the timing circuit
I just shown in the sense that it's
essentially a mass suspended on a spring.
And that's the center of it, and
there is also a whole lot
more going on here obviously.
Here's some of my work.this is
an atomic force microscope.
So this allows us to send things
down to the nanometer scale, and
maybe as little as 1 nanometer chip,
more chip you get 10 nanometer resolution.
I show two different versions here,
both of them have this same thing.
There is, if you look, there is a spring
and there's a mass associated with
that spring, sort of at the end of
the spring, and that allows us to vibrate.
If you look at the one the left, it sort
of has a vibrating type of structure,
like a cantilever or a springboard.
The one on the right is more like
a trampoline or something like that.
In both cases you have a spring and
you have a mass suspended from it, and
that's part of the important operational
characteristics of these devices.
Here's another one.
This is not really a sensor, but it's the
type of stuff that could go into a LIDAR,
for instance.
This is a scanner,
you see there's a mirror right there, and
that mirror is rotating, again,
it's a rotating mass on a spring.
This is they will set in
future LIDAR systems.
And we're really trying to miniaturize
those to make them more efficient.
So LIDAR is the ranging system, an imaging
system they use in self-driving cars.
Maybe the most famous example is the
Texas Instruments projection technology,
they call it
Digital Light Processing Technology.
But that is just a little
aluminum mirrors, and
one of them in the center is ripped off
here to show you the sort of substructure.
And that substructure is very interesting.
But again, it's a spring that sort of
you can see those little white pieces.
Those are springs that connect
it through the mirror, and
the mirror rotates on the spring.
Underneath there's all
kinds of of other things.
There is integrated electronics
in this particular chip,
and that's a theme that I
will return to on occasion.
So again,
you have this mass on this spring.
Here's some of my work going way back.
This is a grating light valve.
These are ribbons that move up and
down to create diffraction patterns
that we can use to modulate light,
and we can also use them as sensors
in different configurations.
This is again, so
these ribbons have a mass.
They have a spring constant to
carry masses on the spring.
So I think I'm trying to make the argument
now that many sensors can be shown,
or can be through described in models,
as a mass on a spring.
So now I'm going to show you a little
bit about how that actually merge.
This is to give you
a little bit of a feel for
how these type of sensors work,
and also how they scale.
That's going to be my main point.
So here we see this is a very
simple spring board that I
put together here on a.
This is actually a hacksaw blade.
If I engage it like that, you can see
that it's a broad based at the frequency.
That's the resting frequency.
The resting frequency is the frequency
where you have maximum energy storage in
terms of mechanical energy in the system.
Now it moves pretty fast here now,
but it is already a sensory.
If I think of this as a sensor, right now
of course it's actually an accelerometer.
It sits in a accelerating field and
it's bent a little bit.
You can't really see it, but
it's very much standing there,
and that's part of the problem that you
need to be able to measure how far bends.
If I wanted to use it as a magnetic
sensor instead, which I could do,
I could bring this magnet in here and
you can see that it starts to bend.
You're using, oop there is snapped,
and now I actually
have a better accelerometer than I had
before at least, it's more sensitive.
Now you can more easily see that it bends.
Now, even with just eyeballing
this you can see that there
is an accelerating field this way.
That's why,
if it was bent that way instead you would
know that I had turned it upside down.
Take a look at this.
When I now engage it, I think that if you
remember back to when I did it before,
it moves quite a bit
faster than it does now.
So there's some things that happened
to the statistics here when I make
it more sensitive.
I made it more sensitive to
gravitational fields to just as a scale,
if you like,
I made a more sensitive scale or
more sensitive accelerometer by doing
this, but I also made it slower.
So that's the point that I want to make.
If you now switch back to my slides
here then we can see that what
I've showed you is essentially the system
that I've shown here in the figure.
There is a spring,
that's the spring constant there k.
There's a mass that's moving on it's,
I didn't talk about this, but there's some
damping, but you can certainly see that
the swinging didn't go on forever.
So damped out,
maybe they didn't damp out fast enough.
I'm looking at it over here.
Now, it's still vibrating, but
it is, the vibration goes down,
so there's the damper, and
then there is something that we
didn't really have in our experiment.
I asked you to just eyeball
how much the thing moved, and
that's some kind of measurement for
how much a mass is actually displaced.
So if I think of this as an accelerometer,
if I modeled an accelerometer this way,
then I have a proof mass m that is
going to be displaced by acceleration.
If I accelerate the whole system and
get a displacement of m going to,
that gives me a force,
m times a, and
that has to equal the spring force.
So I can calculate.
Once I just measure this displacement,
I can calculate the acceleration
that the mass has been subject to
by knowing the spring constants,
measuring the displacement,
and dividing by the mass.
That's my measurement, and
this is how accelerometers work.
This is how they work in your phone,
this is how they work in your car,
this is the exact mechanism that is being
used when an airbag deploys in your car.
So you have to sort of either live with
more and just the simple formula that
tells us what the acceleration is
if you have a certain displacement.
You also have to realize that there
is a bandwidth associated with that,
we have showed you that,
that once I made the displacement larger,
by putting more mass on my spring,
I had a slower resonance frequency.
That's essentially meaning that I can't
measure signals that are fast anymore,
I can only measure slow signals once
I do that, so that's the tradeoff.
The tradeoff is shown here.
Well actually I should
tell you one thing first.
What I asked you to do when we
looked at the video was to just
eyeball the displacement in
a MEMS sensor we don't do that.
We use some kind of adaptor
characteristics to measure displacement,
and in our accelerometer,
we use capacitive measurement.
So now you see that I have the same system
I had before, but I added a little bit.
I added a little circuit here that just
basically puts voltage on these plates,
across these three plates.
So there's a counter electrode down here,
the mass has become an electrode, and
I have an electric field here.
I can now measure the distance
between those two plates by looking at
the capacitance in this circuit,
the capacitance between them.
That's a very, very good measurement.
I can measure very,
very accurate in this way.
I can measure distances that
are much more than the size
of an atom with this type of technique.
So, and this is part of my sort of
small is beautiful argument, that can
really match a very small displacement,
very accurately with this technique.
If I wanted to measure something
that's large, and moves a large rate,
for instance your car is pulling up to
a to a stop sign or a traffic device.
And then after a little
while it's changed,
then it's measuring the position
of your car magnetically.
That's too large distance, and so for
small distances very accurate
measurements you use electric field.
So once you have that,
you have the measurement of precision,
delta z, then you can calculate
the acceleration, like I said.
And I can rewrite that in terms of
that formula that I showed you for
the resonance frequency In this way.
So here, this is really the central
design equation for an accelerometer.
And of course, like I said,
it's not only the accelerometer,
it's always the other sensors and
actuators too.
So unless you wanted to not measure
the smallest possible acceleration in
the given bandwidth.
So you want to go up to certain frequency,
there's certain signals that are so
fast you don't care, but they do care
about certain signals up to a frequency f.
You could try to make that happen by
having very low [INAUDIBLE] and
the very large mass.
And I would get a strong signal but I also
would get a very low resonance frequency.
And if you take a look at that frequency,
resonance frequency,
that's [INAUDIBLE] the square
[INAUDIBLE] over the mass.
So that attempt isn't very good.
Making a good sensor by making
a very weak spring and a large mass.
Well, it sort of works but
it doesn't really work for
the frequency side we're interested in.
What we can try to do is to make
a miniaturized accelerometer.
So now we have a very small mass, but
we also then compensate by making a very,
very weak spring.
It's only really the ratio
to that is important.
So small is okay.
It's okay to have a small mass, because
you can also make it a weak spring and
it still remains in a good,
small, measurable acceleration.
So what it really comes down to is
[INAUDIBLE] is displacement [INAUDIBLE]
very accurately.
[INAUDIBLE], that's nothing to be good
enough using capacitors if you measure
that very, very accurately.
But the key there is to make them so
we [INAUDIBLE] small structures,
because they have excellent
position sensitivity.
And you can just try any resonance
frequency you want, because it's a ratio
of two different quantities of the spring
cross in the mass that matters.
These lead us to matter of main
argument over these last few slides.
Anyone who's used miniaturized sensors and
you want to make
them as small as you can possibly make
them and that's where MEMS comes in.
So MEMS stands for microelectromechanical
systems and like I've said before,
these are systems or sensors that are made
using integrated circuit technology.
This is something that started way back
and Stanford was very central to it.
This is some figures from
an article I read in 1983,
when it was published
in Scientific American.
And James Angell and
the other gentlemen on this
paper were here at Stanford at the time
and they did some very, very cool things.
They wrote about this gas chromatograph,
which is this,
I’m going to explain how that works.
This actually is not an example of
something that's a mass in the spring.
It's a wafer scale integration,
it basically
measure the composition of gases,
the gas mixtures.
This one here in the lower right-hand
corner is an accelerometer, then of course
here, you can immediately recognize
the string right there and the mass.
So I'll know this is
a spring with a mass on it.
So this is exactly what I just showed you.
And then here's another one.
This is a pressure sensor.
If you're measuring just static pressure
if you just try to follow the weather or
something, then maybe the [INAUDIBLE]
frequency isn't that important.
But if you use something like this
as a microphone, [INAUDIBLE] and
many of you have these kinds of
microphones in your cellphones.
Then again, you have your resonance
frequency as the key parameter and
you have the same.
Sort of you have the same argument for
making this as small as possible.
This was an incredibly
powerful article for me.
This is where I did what I did later.
Three years after this came out,
I was a staffer myself.
So and I lived in Norway when I read it.
So this was sort of life altering for me.
Another thing that came out was
article by Kurt E Peterson.
In the particular figure that
I pulled out of that article.
He had article was or the publication was
called Silicon as a Mechanical Material.
And of course, that goes to the heart of
what I'm arguing to, silicon is really it.
That is the best possible
material to make sensors out of.
He solved, and
I'm sort of reproducing that figure here,
a piece of work that was done by
a previous student here at Stanford.
Roylance was her name, and she made
some of the first MEMS accelerometers.
So these are,
basically they're forefathers if you like
of the accelerometers that you have in
your cellphone and in your car right now.
This structure as you see there and
[INAUDIBLE] recognize.
If you look at this structure,
that you have a spring and approved mass,
exactly the same thing as
I've been talking about.
So, when we make MEMS, when we make
microelectricalmechanical systems,
we use many materials.
Essentially if you go through
the periodic table of elements,
almost all of them have been
used in some fashion, either for
fabricating MEMS or
being part of MEMS structures.
But then really the most important parts,
I'm not going to go
through the whole list.
We have a whole large number of
materials that we like to use and
that'd be okay to use.
The silicon is the sort of mainstay,
the one we use always.
And the reason for
that is that's it's stronger then steel,
lighter than aluminum,
and it's single crystal.
Then, it can also be used
in polycrystalline form,
a single crystal in particular,
some very, very good properties.
And there's no other mechanical material
out there that's anywhere like it.
If you think about construction and so
forth, you think about steel maybe.
And steel can be single crystal,
copper can be a single crystal,
but they never are when you
are talking about constructions.
Only silicon is the single
crystalline in mechanical systems,
and that's what makes it so unique.
So just a little bit about silicon,
it's in the group four in
the periodic table of elements.
And therefore, it has the diamond
like structure, same as carbon and
it crystallizes.
That means that there are some
certain planes within silicon
that are more robust than others.
So if you expose it through
chemical [INAUDIBLE],
some planes just won't
etch as well as others.
And that means that you can
make structures like these.
I'm showing you some structures here.
There you can make very
well-defined structures that
are essentially terminating
on the 11 1 planes.
These [INAUDIBLE] planes are more
robust than the other planes.
And what that allows you to do is to
machine very accurately in parallel, and
that's the key point.
You can make machine in parallel.
To think about a machine shop,
you have a machine there,
you take a piece of aluminum or
a piece of steel, and you machine it.
You do it at one at a time.
If you go back to that, that's
a visual light processing technology.
These instruments they have a million
little machines on their chip.
You couldn't possibly
make them one by one.
So this idea of making
them all in parallel and
making them by chemistry
as opposed to by machining.
Machining by chemistry if you like,
that's very central and
here's how you start that.
And here are some of
those typical sensors.
One thing that was very popular for
a long time was to use piezoresistive
sensors to do the measurement
of displacement.
Actually, capacity before,
this is again from that same paper that
Where the pressure sensor in
the lower right here is from
that Scientific American article
by Anschiel and his coworkers.
So this is one example of how you make
a pressure sensor that is actually not
capacitive in this particular case but
uses another transduction mechanism.
One thing that made a huge Impact on the
silicon valley was using these things for
inkjet nozzles, so this is the basis of
that transformation that happened within
HP, Hewlett Packard, when they became sort
of a printer company for a few years.
This is a part of an inkjet printer.
Of course that was something that's
maybe has come and gone but it was very,
very important for a long time.
So this is by machining
things out of silicon, so
out of material that I think so highly of.
Another way of making micromachines
is to deposit layers on
top of silicon and then shape that.
And this is the sort of
canonical example of that.
This is a Combdrive that could be sitting
in something like a timing circuit or
an exometer, and in fact, that particular
technology has been taken
to extremes by a number
of companies and also institutions
around the United States.
So Sandia in particular made a very,
very sophisticated
surface micromachining process that
you can make almost anything in.
So and
then of course surface micromachining
is also the underlying technology for
that digital light processing technology
that I already talked about a little bit.
Another aspect of fabrication that
sort of leads up to modern day
micromachining in MEMS is
deep reactive ion etching.
Some of the most seminal work
in deep reactive ion etching for
MEMS is also done here at Stanford.
How it works is that when you try to etch
into silicon you tend to sort of get
shapes that are not exactly ideal.
So if you take a look at that cross
section in the upper left hand corner,
I started to etch into silicon, I'd get
these slopes that were rounded side walls.
And what I could do then, and what
happens automatically in this process,
in deep reactive ion etching,
is that I deposit a polymer.
And then I etched a polymer
at the bottom of that hole.
I executed a directional etch so
that the bottom is exposed and
I can repeat the process.
And I get, instead of sort of getting
a very large or rounded sidewall,
I get a sidewall that consists of
these scallops, little scallops, and
they can be very, very small.
So essentially, even, I've done this.
I keep repeating this,
this deposit polymer then etch,
deposit polymer then etch process,
I get something like what I show here
in the bottom at right hand corner where
I basically get straight side walls.
This was a huge first step forward,
because now we can shape
things differently.
Now you were no long dependent on the
crystalline orientation of our silicon.
Now we can shape it more arbitrarily, so
you can do things like I'm showing here.
This is a very much used
type of vapor in maps,
it's silicon insulator, what it means
is I have taken a silicon wafer,
deposited oxide on it and then put a layer
of silicon on top of that oxide again, so
that's where I'm showing on the top here.
And then we just take that DRIE and
just shape that top layer
into whatever we want.
And then we remove from oxide underneath,
from where we want to let them
have free stranding structures.
This is essentially the basis process for
a large number of MEMS devices.
And here is sort of just one example.
This is close to 20 years old now, so it's
not sort of the modern type necessarily.
And there is a couple of
points I wanted to make here.
It's a very simple process.
Therefore the structure that you see
is made in one mask in an SOI wafer,
and it has a very,
very powerful functionality.
It's actually a fiber optic switch,
this particular example.
The point I want to make
is that it's way too large.
I said that's MEMS One of
the fundamental reasons to use MEMS,
and particularly in the Internet of
Things is that you're going to have so
many sensors, and
that they are super small.
So, the question is how do we take this
type of technology I talked about there,
the chemical machining,
the surface micromachining, and the DRIE,
how do we combine those to
make really small sensors?
That I think is where the futures are,
very, very small sensors.
And here's one example, this is from my
own work where we've been able to put
a large number of the third
functionalities together,
this is an atomic force
microscope that is so
small that it fits on
the facet of an optical fiber.
A standard optical fiber is 125 microns,
so
that's a little bit more than
a tenth of a millimeter in diameter.
And the output, a fully functional
atomic force microscope on top of it.
So that is sort of a tour de
force in fabrication if you like.
But it also shows that we now have
the technologies to go smaller.
One of the key technologies behind that
particular development is shown here,
that's Hydrogen Annealing, so If you
start out with a piece of silicon and
you print at low pressure
in a hydrogen ambient, and
heat it up a little bit,
you'll actually get sort of
a reconformation of the silicon,
it will flow.
It still stay in sort of
a single crystalline form but
it can make all kinds of very
very interesting devices.
What I'm showing here is on
the left of a photonic crystal,
on the right I'm showing that how we
can actually use this to make boards,
I'm going to later in a little bit
more careful detail later, one of in
the picture in the lower left hand side,
no sorry, lower right hand side.
It's one of my favorites because you
can actually see in those boards that
are created you can see
the crystalline facets of the silicon.
So we are showing that this is
in fact sort of a crystalline
material and even that these
boards show this very clearly.
So just to show you,
this is what I think is the basis for
a number of sort of very important
MEMS sensors going forward,
sort of assess a technology
that allows you to make more or
less arbitrary shapes of silicon and
I'm demonstrating that here.
So we start here with a, following
it numerically from one and then up.
There's a piece of silicon,
we deposit a matching layer,
we pattern something into
the non-matching level three.
And then we etch into the silicon.
So only one match so far, and
in fact there can only be one match.
And then I do a little
trick there in number five,
I cover everything
conformally with a thin cell.
And then in six, I've continued my trick,
I've now removed things from the bottom.
That's just a sort of an idea
we got from the DRIE, right,
I remove things from,
for example, surfaces.
The top surface doesn't matter,
which is already covered by such
a thick patternating layer.
And then I go and actually
the silicon with a directional etch,
and in number eight, I go through with
a isotype with an isotropic aspect,
created these spheres for
me, these spherical hollows.
And then I continue.
I just do the same thing again in nine,
directionally a bit further down I
do the conformal coverage in tank,
I do the removal from horizontal
surface [INAUDIBLE] 11.
I continue the action trial.
I do another, this time much longer.
As the [INAUDIBLE] catch in 13, and then
I remove all the cultivation in 14 and
the I have that structure
that you see there.
And then, some of the magic happens,
because going from 14 to 15, what I've
done is that I've done the hydrogen anneal
where I have re-flowed the silicon.
And that allows me to make this very,
very complex structure.
It may be, this is a cross-section and
sort of a cartoonish thing, so
I want to show you some SEMs of that same
thing to really show you what it looks
like in real life.
So this is before.
This is at level 14 in
the fabrication process.
Now we're going to cut it off so
you can see what it really looks like.
There is this hole down in the silicon,
there is a spherical hole partway down,
and then there's a void that
is continuous that stretches from
hole to hole further down again.
At the top you can see it's
just these cylindrical holes.
And now then we do the magic.
Like I said, now we do the hydrogen
anneal, and then this is what happens.
So if you now see that
those spherical holes that
I hide in the upper layer
have turned in to voids and
they actually, the silicon flows on top
of them and enclosed underneath them.
And it left two structures, it left
these voids and they are separate and
it left a sort of
continuous void underneath.
Now I really have, this is actually
a very good pressure sensor.
We tested this in many different design.
Because that, Sector or the small,
spherical voids on top,
it comes through a photonic crystal
that gives me higher productivity.
So we actually use an optical readout,
an optical interferometric readout to make
this into a very,
very precise pressure sensor.
The whole structure is made right there.
I think that you would agree with me that
there is very few limitations on what I
can make in terms of shapes with this.
And the really, really nice thing about
it is that these are single crystalline
silicon, and they are extremely small.
And those two points hang together,
because by making things
out of crystalline silicon,
I can make things very small and
still have them be very, very robust.
I can control the process better so I can
go through very thin films and so forth.
So this is a very, very,
powerful nanotechnology.
Here I'm just showing a simplification
of what I just showed you.
This time I forgot the,
I forego making that upper layer and
I just make it void, so if you see that
down there at ten I just made it void.
This is a pressure sensor by itself.
The diaphragm is now hitting
on top of a reference cavity,
that is essentially very little pressure
inside of the void that I created because
when we do the re-flow, the hydrogen
anneal, that's very low pressures.
And then we end up with something at
the very tip, defined pressure sensor.
And simplification is super
important here, I believe.
You need to have things that are simple
if you're going to go to the Internet and
things.
So that's why I love this
particular pressure sensor.
It's just silicon.
And it has just a void in it.
And I can read it out capacitively
like we talked about before.
How much that upper diaphragm has display,
where it can measure its optic rate.
There is a number of different things I
can do with that, but it's super simple.
That brings me to sort of the point
I wanted to make about smart sensors.
Since I've been working with, like I said,
in 1983 I got super excited about MEMS and
I decided to come to
Stanford to study that.
And worked with these people,
I never actually worked with James Angell,
but I did play golf with him a few times.
He's unfortunately passed away now,
he was a great person.
But I worked with people
here who worked with MEMS.
And one of the conundrums for
MEMS is the idea that since your making
it from silicon, you should put
some intelligence into the sensor.
And I showed you examples of that already
by the Texas Instruments technology.
There's a set of switching transistors and
underneath the mirrors that I showed you.
Analog Devices is
a company that does really,
maybe around a third of
them in commercial arts.
In capacity of exerometers and gyros.
And they also have integrated electronics
on chip and other examples of that.
There are few out there but not many
because it is very difficult to do that.
So, then we were talking about
the Internet of things where
the sensors are going to
be a bit cruder so
you might have to go a much cheaper
element than you can get with this.
Cross the same thing or estimate,
reduce MEMS and CMOS together.
I don't believe that that is going
to drive the Internet of things.
I think that what we really have to
do is to do what I'm saying here at
the bottom to assemble things together.
Assemble the electronics together
with very simple sensors to
make the simplest possible devices and
systems that we can make.
So that sort of makes it back
to the Internet of things.
So like the proverbial elephant,
the Internet of things depends completely
on your perspective, or what part of
the elephant you grab on to, right?
I'm sort of grabbing [INAUDIBLE] by
the sensors that you have understood.
They are the most important part but
that's, of course, my perspective.
I think that that's where the real
world meets the digital world and
that's the most important.
Other people say no, no, no.
Come on,
the sensors have been around forever.
What really is new here is
the Internet and the machine learning.
And then of course what's exciting is what
this can do for innovation and so forth.
What are we going to do with big data?
And then of course other people say no,
what's really most important is how you
implement all this in the circuits and
the embedded systems and so forth.
So exactly what the Internet of things is,
and
what's most important,
I think is a question that I can't answer.
My take is that the sensors
are the most important,
those are the ones that enable things.
But I think I do can say a little about
opportunities and the cool applications,
so let me have a stab at that.
One thing I've been hearing a lot about is
that, and everybody is excited about it is
autonomous vehicles, particularly cars but
it also extends to airplanes,
drones, underwater exploration,
and aerial mapping and so forth.
So here's sort of my
little animation of that.
So right now, the way most of
the autonomous vehicles operate is that
they have a LIDAR, that stands for
light detection and ranging.
And basically what I'm showing is a laser
beam sort of scanning across the field
of view, registering things where
things are, it's almost like a camera.
They have a little bit information
because it can give you
a little bit of motion information and
so forth.
And it also has maybe bad
resolution at a distance.
But basically you're getting
an image of what's going on.
And that's not what our eyes
do when we are driving.
We do something quite different.
We are the environment,
we don't photograph it,
sort of with a certain frame rate.
We watch areas of interest.
And we also are very good
at picking up emotion.
And that's what we need to in
sort of future self-driving cars.
So here's sort of what
I think it should do.
It shouldn't just scan across,
it should take a look.
There comes a dog running out,
I have to look at it.
So that's what a human does.
You just look at the tree after
all because the trees there,
they topple over and
that's a problem if they move.
But mostly, they're standing still and
they're going to continue to stand still,
sort of at least assumption.
So awareness is really what
the Internet can teach us all about,
being aware of the environment.
One way to do that,
to get that functionality I just
showed you is used phased arrays.
So this is one possible solution.
We are working with that,
the scanning mechanisms that allows you to
jump in any sort of in your field of view.
Not scan, sort of get the full picture,
at the same time you're
looking at exactly what's important,
just like a human would.
And that's where some of the and
batches are going to come when you
actually have a self-driving car.
I do think that there's a very good chance
that it's going to operate a little bit
more like a human in terms of
what it actually senses and
what it pays attention to.
And that's what this particular
technology allows you to do.
This is a MEMS phased array.
I'm not going to talk too
much about how it works but
it's essentially the same kind
of structure again, right?
Mouth and the sprig.
Here's some other things that I
think that are super exciting, but
also very troubling in some sense.
We have wearables and that's not really
a big deal, everyone's wearing a Fitbit or
something like that these days.
Then you can ingest sort of diagnostic
devices in pills and so forth.
That's a little bit more invasive.
And of course, I'm working in the horrible
end of this being implantable sensors.
What I'm showing here in the upper
right-hand corner is an implantable
microscope that allows you to follow
cancer progression in animal models.
So this is sort of very invasive.
They can also give you
a lot of new information.
And then the one on
the bottom right is our srot
of implantable microphone, I should say.
I basically look at sort of acoustic
fields in the body and how those,
what they tell us about
the different diseases and so forth.
These are very, very exciting fields and
one of the people are really
going into this examples here.
A young professor Aida Pru who's has
actually put together some of this slide.
She is in the process of revolutionizing
this, and improving all aspects of it.
And you will see more and more,
in particularly, sort of the ingestible,
the implantable sensors
are just starting out.
Now, so this is what they are and I think
that you can expect to see more of them.
They've brought up some of the challenges
and opportunities that they represent.
You're going to get, just more and
more health records [INAUDIBLE] and
you need to integrate actually can really
sort of get [INAUDIBLE] information.
That's a big data problem, and
mainly machine learning problem.
Data security of course,
is super important,
you don't want people to
hack our informatiion.
But here's another thing,
that I'm talking about here.
False positives,
if you have a sensor that tells you
that you might have a symptom that is
problematic, then you go to your doctor.
So the doctor's office is going to
be full of healthy people, but
they are anxious about some device that
they have that tells them something.
Now that, of course, if you ask doctors,
they will say that's
going to be a huge problem.
That's going to be a nightmare,
this is not going to work.
But you can't turn that around,
because there's an energy there,
people care about their own health.
What we really need to get to is that,
you don't really just go and
bother the doctors about false positives.
What we do is that we become
an assistant to the doctor,
say somebody can actually work with them,
the doctor on the team.
And I think that
the Internet of Things and
sort of it goes to medical sensors
are going to help us do that.
Now, so in terms of opportunity, if you
an find the business model that allows
you to tap into that energy that people
have about caring about their own health.
I think you will win big.
I don't know how to do that.
This has so many aspects to it,
[INAUDIBLE] is only one of them.
So to end up,
then what do I see as the big
opportunities of the Internet of Things?
And what are the cool applications?
I think that the Internet of Things, like
I said, even if I can't really define it,
it's by awareness.
That's really one way to,
if you want to use one word that
describes the usefulness of
the Internet of Things, it's awareness.
It's going to lead to efficiency,
safety, sustainability.
In transportation and
healthcare, food in production,
transportation, storage, preparation.
You're going to get smart cities,
smart homes, and
it's beginning to have a lot more
awareness of what's going on around us.
And if you talk about from
a company point of view,
if you want to sort of entrepreneurship
kind of point of view.
It's going to be a lot of people trying
to develop business concepts around this.
So you really have to be unique,
you have to have your own secret sauce,
I think unique sensors is easy for
me to think about.
How do you make the censors unique.
It's not that you can measure things that
haven't been measured before, but you're
going to use them in different ways and
you can integrate them in different ways.
You're going to communicate
with them in different ways,
that's a unique [INAUDIBLE]
that you need to develop.
You can also be unique on how you execute.
That's a lot harder,
at least from my point of view.
And of course,
people are going to win there too.
Part of the execution is how you
actually do some of these things for
the circuits and the battery systems.
Have better user interface
I think is super important.
We really need to solve
the big data problem by having
machines take that over and present us
with information as opposed to data.
Maybe the most exciting things about
the Internet are things that can be
effective in so many positive ways.
If you work on that, you have sort of so
many opportunities to do good, and
as you also do round, that's okay.
But I think that doing good is really,
really what makes me excited
about the Internet of Things.
So with that, I'm going to thank you for
this thing and
I hope that you have some questions.
And we're going to take
those now I believe.
Yeah, so I will start by the question
about limitations or on miniaturization.
The question is,
is there any limitation for
miniaturization [INAUDIBLE]
structure reaches the nanoscale?
And clearly there is such limitation,
there are such limits.
Once you are getting down towards
the sizes that are comparable
to sort of atomic distances or
a separation [INAUDIBLE] material.
They have a distinct or
very well-defined atomic
distance between the nearest neighbors.
Once you start to approach that course,
everything that I talked
about becomes very different.
So I think that you can take many of
the crosshairs that we have made and scale
them down into the hundreds of nanometers
certainly and maybe tenths of nanometer.
But once we smaller than that,
and of course,
that's where electronics already is,
right?
So the manufacturing base for
going to those kinds of sizes are there.
We can go there, I've read the technology
has been developed for electronics.
I have a hard time seeing sensors that
were the overall sensor is
less than ten nanometers.
That would be crazy, it sounds to me.
So maybe somewhere in the tens of
nanometers where the limits are where we
had to sort of start doing
things very differently.
Yes, so I think that sort
of answers that question.
So the next question goes to
this thing about integration.
Is it possible to etch MEMS sensors on the
same silicon dye as an integrated circuit?
And that is possible, and there
are many strong examples of that, and
I keep bringing it up this digital
life processing technology of
Texas Instruments.
I think that's a tour de force
in technology development.
It has some,
Electronics sort of underneath and
then you have built MEMS on top.
So that's definitely one example of that,
and
there's several other companies
that's done the same thing.
I think that to do that, if you look
at the Texas Instruments' Technology,
it's only rarely updated, because it's so
difficult to do an update
of a technology like that.
It took a long time to develop.
I'm not going to try to hatch at a guess
as to the total development budget, but
it was going to be in
the hundreds of millions.
And that means that only a few
applications can be reached,
can really have ambition to do
something as complex as that.
So I think that for most Internet of
Things sensors, you will not do that,
just simply because there are other
ways that more cost effective,
with the type of diversity that we
expect to see in the Internet of Things.
And then there's a couple of
questions about reliability,
And so let me just read a couple of other
questions like this other question.
Is there any mechanical
wear out with time for
MEMS sensors and
of course [INAUDIBLE] more things.
And the next question is along
the same lines is that MEMS currently
undergo extensive testing
during manufacture.
What is your current thinking on
long term testing on MEMS that
are in current operation,
question is on reliability factors.
So I'm just talking about
reliability in general first.
There is a large number of
MEMS sensors out there.
Actually we expect to
reach a trillion sensors.
A very small fraction,
that maybe one in a thousand or
one in a hundred is going to
be on Internet of Things.
There are many systems that aren't
going to be connected like that.
And they are from these sensors and
been talking about billions of them now.
It's from an excellent reliability and
it isn't strange,
because the smaller things are,
the more robust they are.
And of course, can you also add
that this is the best material
known to man in terms of purity and
it's a clean crystal,
it's a monolithic crystal in many cases.
Long term stability is excellent for
all MEMS devices.
Let me just take one sort of example,
it's somewhat facetious, but
if you take a BMW with many people
that says it's an okay car, right?
And you shake it and we'll find that
the first resonance frequency is
somewhere in the tenths of Hertz.
That means that it it's
really not that good.
You should take a MEMS device and
shake it and you try to look for
their first resonance frequency,
it might be in the millions of Hertz,
in the megaHertz, or
at least in the hundreds of kiloHertz.
Basically what I'm saying
is that any MEMS device or
any good well defined designed MEMS
device is something on the order of
10,000 to 100,000 times
more light than a BMW.
Now I am being facetious.
It does go to its reliability.
Now, there was a more specific question
in there that had to do with how we test,
and that is difficult.
I think that it is clear that the Internet
of Things is such an explosive route that
we are not going to test enough.
For some of these application is going to,
like you have to do more testing.
As a general rule,
I think that MEMS is very irreliable,
therefore you have to test for it.
The next question has to do with
something I didn't touch on at all,
and that is about how do
you power these sensors.
So the question is about
energy harvesting method.
Are there any MEMS sensors that can be
self-powered by harvesting ambient energy?
And, again, this is a big field, I didn't
talk about it, it's very, very important.
If you're going to have sensors
everywhere, having bad ratios course
possible, some of these sensors
are using very little energy and
you can waste them up occasionally
when you need to read the data.
And that could get you into very,
very small, sort of power,
through average powers,
so you might be able to,
on the even very small batteries
operate for ten years.
But of course,
what's eluded to here, well,
energy harvesting is [INAUDIBLE] very,
very interesting.
So the most obvious is use solar cells and
things of that nature if you are operating
in an environment where that makes sense.
Even an indoor environment has
a lot of light energy, typically.
So you can combine that way
through a rechargeable battery.
You can have something that
essentially lasts forever.
I should put that in quotes
because nothing lasts forever, but
at least you don't have sort of
a power lifetime that's obvious.
There's also a number of
developments that goes to
things like extracting
energy from vibrations.
So if you have a pressure sensor in a car
tire, and that's more and more common
these days, so that you know whether you
actually have a problem with your tires.
You don't really want to
have a battery in there.
But there's also a lot,
there's high energy environment
because all the rotation.
So you should be able to,
you might have a battery but
it's a rechargeable battery that recharges
through that energy that you can extract
from the rotation that's going on.
So energy harvesting,
that is super important.
And when you say that the MEMS
sensors are self-powering,
that's quite a different question though,
because now you're talking
about the sensor itself being
the energy harvester, too.
And my general feeling there is that's
better to separate those two functions
into two different devices and put them
together into a real functioning system.
>> So we're at the top of the hour, so
to be thoughtful of everyone's time,
why don't you take two more questions,
Olav?
>> Okay, yeah.
So let's see, the next one,
I haven't read it.
So let's see, reality of the job.
Now how do you see IoT devices catching
brain waves down metabolism and
help with deep learning disease
prevention other body cures?
That's actually more than one question,
I think, but
let me try to take a stab at that.
There's definitely, and I did mention
Ada Prune as one of the premiere
researchers in this field who, lots of
people are interested in neurology.
And they're using both sort
of popular genetics and
also a number of different
kinds of probes.
Some of them are based on MEMS technology.
So the brain makes it sort of a little bit
of a nebulous term for me but as neurology
and sort of action potential and things
of that nature are being measured with
sensors and they will be part of
the Internet of Things at some point.
Although now we talk about something
that's very, very invasive.
So exactly when that kind of data will
be part of the Internet of Things is not
obvious to me.
And some of the metabolism and so forth,
It's something that is much
more straightforward, and
we have quite a few sensors that are sort
of in a micro [INAUDIBLE] system.
So we do all kinds of things like
drug discovery and so forth.
And there, there's a large
number of MEMS sensors there.
Deep learning,
of course, I think this is disconnected
from the first part of the question.
Deep learning is a super
important part of Of
the internet of things I mention machine
learning deep learning a variation
of that I'm not going to go into
the details of the difference.
But the deep learning is
absolutely essential for
dealing with the big data that we're
going to get from all these sensors.
And so that part of questions,
how does this plane do [INAUDIBLE]
prevention and other body [INAUDIBLE]?
Having more data must help but
it's not all this how you do that.
This is really one of the key questions
and maybe one of key challenges or
we could turn it around key opportunities
of how do we actually more data to
make healthcare more efficient and
hopefully also less expensive and
also you have better outcome.
Not obvious that has going to happen and
doctors are petrified of it.
Yeah, so I think the last question,
I'm concerned about people hacking into
self-driving cars and
another large subject that cause harm.
What are the safeguards?
This initial course very well
founded because I did [INAUDIBLE]
has been examples all ready
of cars being hacked into and
people if they were malicious I think
most of the examples we heard about.
How people do with the demonstration
where they could have
done things like lock the wheel and
stuff like that.
I think that this is definitely
dangerous territory.
I want to take parts
that we have the same.
This is actually something that
needs to be studied very carefully.
Now, take the self driving
car as an example.
I think that they have to be aggressive in
employing them, even in spite of the fact
that I really don't have a good answer for
this question.
And the reason for that roughly speaking,
40,000 people die in traffic in
the United States every year.
If we can reduce that
number substantially,
even if we are opening ourselves up for
malicious hacking, if the total
outcome is that we reduce that number
substantially and you have to go for it.
That's why I think you
have to be aggressive.
But this question, of course, points
to some of the most frightening things
around the whole Internet, and
I don't know what the safeguards are,
other than being very vigilant and making
the systems as hack-proof as possible.
And if we are to believe certain
[INAUDIBLE], we don't even
have a hack proof electrical
system in this country, right.
So, it's a very tough question and
I don't really know the answer, but
in some cases we have to go
forward without being 100% secure.
In other cases, the downside is so huge
that we just basically cannot take a risk.
So maybe one way to answer the questions
is we basically have to parse
the risk-reward, and
go forward where it makes sense.
>> Great thank you Olav so much for
a wonderful presentation for
taking time to answer all these attendee
questions and there were many we even
couldn't get to which shows me how
much interest there is in this field.
A reminder to all of the attendees,
recordings will be made available within a
week and sent out to those who registered.
And we just want to thank you.
Thank you so much for taking the time to
attend today and we'll see you at our next
webinar and hopefully in our internet
of things graduate certificate as well.
Thanks so much.